so the FAA has now lifted of course that
ground stop and as you heard they're
looking into exactly what caused that
outage and here at home Reed
International seen more than 300 delays
50 cancellations today Mary Jane
beliesza shares how passengers are
reacting
Travelers at Harry Reid International
Airport tell me they're just happy to
touch down in Las Vegas after an FAA
outage delayed their trips the FAA says
a system went down that notifies Pilots
about closed runways equipment outages
and more on a flight route the agency
says the problem was fixed early this
morning but the delay already impacted
more than 300 flights here at Harry Reid
International Airport including John
stambaugh's flight we were about a half
an hour 45 minutes out of Atlanta and
the pilot came on and said that we had
they had to divert to Knoxville
Tennessee we sat on the tarmac there for
about an hour and a half he says it was
a smooth flight to Vegas after finally
taking off from Atlanta it was an
inconvenience but I'm not disappointed
you know I'm I'm happy I'm in Las Vegas
to meet my friends and so it's onward
and upward also arriving from Atlanta
Lisa Pender says she wasn't going to let
this light delay ruin her fun this this
trip has been like three years in the
making and we finally just made it so
yeah last time was covered so
so when I was like this time really FAA
really after hearing about the outage
Pender contacted her sister Amanda
Harris she calls me and I'm like hey
karumba and so so I get to the airport
and they push me back and then they
pushed me back again and Harris Herod
finally flew into Las Vegas via
Southwest after an hour delay in San
Diego we didn't think we were gonna make
it so we're super grateful that we did
you know the flights stayed even if they
were late we got here and now we'll
enjoy ourselves and have fun and food
and entertainment we're here from today
until Monday so that's like a for real
adult vacation for us it was like yes